pô
toda a gente diz ainda a vossa mãe pai
dessa moça namorada país a vossa família
e do país todo mundo pega mas só um
pequeno problema
falei quando vocês querem mandar aqui o
pai do gostoso mas tem um monte de todos
os lados ninguém sabe mandar um país sem
ser apanhado e é por isso que hoje vos
vou ensinar é como mandar um país sem
que ninguém note o irmão só usamos aqui
neste jogo é um jogo bastante futurista
mas não as tenha ordenado em 3 depois de
mais de um chefe do setor e da textura
mas enfim o jogo é em chinês o movimento
só chinesa é que inventou os jogos onde
mandou um país né o jogo chamas já nem
desde um delay andaram tanto essas são
as instruções
por isso nós podemos usar a tecla espaço
e podemos usar a tecla prazo e não de
que 80 no dinheiro de léa
mas acho que está tudo a mesma coisa eu
acho que é só cuidar da época estamos
aqui na nossa coragem e quando os carros
passam nós basicamente temos que cuidar
nós temos que aproveitar o som dos
carros para me hospedar uns sabem que é
uma pessoa leal lado para que nós não
estamos a treinar há lei vincou pedro eu
consegui 94 940 de conclusão do pai do
foi um bom passo importante foi dado que
tu ainda não aceita mais letras da
equipe por um mês da equipe do agora eu
não sair vou cantar nesta ou pouco tempo
atrás quanto vai vejo este jogo é 2004
foi em 2016 é que eu peguei meu estilo
mas não começou atrasada em tudo na vida
tudo tem que esperar pelo carro vai ser
aquela barriga embaixo não pode servir
para o vermelho não eu perca conciliada
plate estudo
aí o quase campeão é mais um carro
ganhou de mim pelos grandes
ela ganhou ganhou meu sério carros de
fórmula 1 numa estrada nacional é isso
mesmo foi concluso ao fotoperíodo um
tronco
eu não sou eu não consigo andar em
condições para o jogo difícil o banco
foi do ensio zhuhai os grandes agora vai
passar por um momento não tão bem
fininho mais um como é difícil eu tenho
que chegar à barra coxa
depois de um tempo eu não ouviu a matar
quase solta o mestre dos peidos milton
aguentar muito tempo o meu deus gente
colocava descontinuou acabam infinito a
área ouvir o que ela viu meu e só
engraçadas ano eu contar que eu peguei
um fininho eo engraçado do que os
caminhões é compreensível agora carlos
fórmula 1
depois o tempo na bunda não tá bom não
dá só para isso vamos ser o pai nós
fizemos 3190 a dose do caso eu não sei
porque o pedrinho o paa agora foi um dos
que entram têm uma opinião não é assim
no meu estúdio é difícil ouvir o meu faz
um tapa com essa passar para lá que eu
descobri uma coisa nova aqui eu posso
mandar bufas buffet ou pedir silêncio
que ninguém o fofo
o paa agora quase que eu cheguei com
esta causa da roupa que você vá eu ainda
é medir isto retira
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque
com isto espero que vocês tenham gostado
dos meus peitos uma massa foi 3.160
conseguirem se cuidar mais do que eu
manco o twitter o inscrito para o ver
esse pessoal espero que tenham gostado
já sabem quanto como falar em favorito
fiquem bem e até a próxima